so in 2016 I was commissioned to produce
a photo essay about the water crisis in
Flint Michigan and that's been going on
since 2014 and I accepted the Commission
with the idea that I would photograph
three generations of women dealing with
a crisis on a daily basis I was
fortunate to meet two best friends
artists activists and poets amber Hassan
and Shay Cobb who took me around Flint
as a school bus driver shake ah became
the central figure of the photo essay
along with her mother miss Renee and her
eight-year-old daughter Zion I
obsessively followed a school bus routes
and when Shay wasn't driving the bus she
would be watching over Zion making sure
she was studying I embedded myself in
every intimate facet of Shay's life when
Shay took me to Zion in school and I saw
the water fountains covered with signs
that said contaminated do not drink I
couldn't pick up my camera to photograph
it it rocked me to the core to see that
in America we can go from fountains that
say whites are blacks only to today
seeing fountains that say contaminated
water do not drink and somehow that's
acceptable the residents in Flint have
been forced to drink with cook with and
bathe with bottled water while paying
the highest water bills in the country
for water that is infected with deadly
Legionella bacteria it was natural for
me to go to Flint because industrial
pollution bacteria contaminated water
were all too familiar from me growing up
in my hometown
Braddock Pennsylvania where my mother
and I battled cancer and autoimmune
disorders like lupus our 14-year
collaboration the notion of family was
created out of our struggle to survive
environmental racism health care
inequity and chemical emissions that
were being deregulated and released from
the United States still corporation
making Braddock the town with the
highest asthma and infant infant
mortality rates in the country from the
Monongahela River to the Flint River in
the words of w eb Du Bois the town the
whole valley has turned its back upon
the river it is used it as a sewer as a
drain as a place for throwing their
waste General Motors has been cited for
dumping chemicals in the Flint River for
decades when my photo-essay Flint his
family came out in August of 2016 it was
released to remind America that although
Flint was no longer headline news the
water crisis was far from over and of
course I knew it was going to take more
than a series of photographs on my part
to bring relief to the people in vehicle
city say and I bonded over our mothers
and grandmothers amber and I bonded over
our battles with lupus together we
decided to remain in each other's life
and continue our creative efforts in
2017 Shay and amber co-founded artist
collective the sister tour whose mission
is to provide a safe space for Flint
artists one year later I mounted my solo
exhibition Flint is family here in New
York City at Gavin Brown's Enterprise on
West 127th Street as the audience
approach is the facade of the building
they see a 30-foot billboard the 30-foot
billboard is May
three large color negatives with the
message water is life spelled out in
Nestle water bottles by the sister tour
Nestle the largest water bottling
company in the world
pumps 400 gallons of water per minute
out of aquifers in Lake Michigan nearly
free of charge
the company also extracts millions of
liters of water from First Nation
reservations while they have no access
to clean water at all this is a
fundraiser print that I used to raise
money to send the sister tour to
different venues to educate people on
the ongoing crisis I also continue to
keep it in the public eye by producing
countdown flags that were raised on
institutions across the country this
past June Amber emailed me with the news
that Michigan's Attorney General dropped
all criminal charges in the Flint water
crisis investigation where eight state
and city employees were facing charges
as serious as manslaughter
I could no longer idly stand by and wait
for the government to do its job justice
has been delayed and justice has been
denied it's been five years and we're
still waiting on justice for the men
women and children in Flint
I asked amber what can I do she told me
about a man named Moses West that she
met in Puerto Rico who invented a twenty
six thousand pound atmospheric water
generator Amber took Moses to elected
officials in the city of flint none of
them seemed interested in bringing the
machine for relief to Flint at all amber
needed to get the machine from a
military base in Texas all the way to
Flint nobody in Flint had that kind of
money lying around and it was at that
point that I decided to take the
proceeds from my soul
exhibition Flynn his family along with a
generous match grant from the Robert
Rauschenberg Foundation and sent it to
Moses West this past July Moses West and
his atmospheric water generator arrives
to Flint Michigan on North Saginaw
between Marengo and Pulaski and it's
actually still there right now operating
this community that sits three miles
from downtown has been stripped of its
schools access to healthy grocery stores
and clean water socially it's viewed as
a violent poor community but I see
something completely different
Moses an officer Ranger veteran was very
clear about his water rescue mission
bring relief a free clean water to the
people in Flint teach them how to use
the machine teach them how to take care
of it and most importantly take
ownership of the machine tell everybody
across the city to bring all their
containers and come and take as much
water as they can stock up on especially
before the winter season hits the
machine doesn't extract moisture in
freezing temperatures
this technology pulls air through a high
volume air filter it mechanically
creates condensation which produces
2,000 gallons of water per day residents
are free to walk up to the machine
anywhere between 9 a.m. and 8 p.m. daily
and take as much as they want
alleviating them from standing in long
lines for bottled water I've been at the
Machine interviewing people asking them
what does it mean to see Moses and his
machine in their community and what has
it been like living without access to
clean water Aleta told me it's a miracle
that God gave Moses the knowledge and
technology to provide us with pure
drinking water she also told me that
prior to the machine coming she had
severe headaches and that the water made
her so sick to her stomach she couldn't
eat Tina told me that the lead
contaminated water made her hair fall
out usually she's weak and very
lightheaded since using the machine
she's had energy and strength David he
was overwhelmed with joy that someone
from Texas cared when he tasted the
water he thought to himself now this is
the way God intended water to be he
brings three seven gallon containers to
refill to use at his barbecue stand
through creativity and solidarity Amber
Hassan Sheikh AAB to clear Senegal the
sister tour myself the people of Flint
Dexter moon Moses West and his
atmospheric water generator have been
able to provide 120 thousand gallons of
free clean water the people in Flint
deserve access to clean water water is
life it is the spirit that binds us from
sickness death and destruction imagine
how many millions of lives we could save
if Moses machine were in places like
Newark New Jersey South Africa and India
with compassion instead of profit
motives I loaded my camera I locked my
focus and I placed my finger over the
shutter release as che and Zion went to
take their first sip of clean water when
the shutter released I was overcome with
a deep sense of joy in righteousness
when I sent che some of the photographs
she wrote think
you again for the light that you bring
to my city I immediately replied the
light was already there within you it's
been 4 years since I've been
photographing in Flint and finally I've
been able to render a poetic justice no
matter how dark a situation may be a
camera can extract the light and turn a
negative into a positive
thank you
[Applause]